ich liebe Schnitzel er liebt Schnitzel
sie liebt Schnitzel mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit liebst auch du
Schnitzel von klein auf kennt man das
hier ein wunderschönes zartes du flirtes
knuspriges Wiener Schnitzel
wahrscheinlich wenn ich das so
beschreibe kriegt ihr auch schon Lust
auf ein richtig gutes Schnitzel und
heute zeige ich euch ein richtig gutes
Schnitzel nicht irgendeins sondern
meiner Meinung nach das beste in ganz
Deutschland und das gibt es hier in
meiner Heimatstadt Köln und bevor ihr
euch fragt wer will nicht dass ich das
entscheiden kann ich war in Wien habe
dort das beste Schnitzel gesucht war bei
Meißel und Schaden war bei viel Gemälde
war auch hier in Deutschland bei
Borchers in Berlin und bei vielen vielen
Orten die behaupten ein sehr gutes
Schnitzel zu haben als ich aber aus Wien
wieder kam und das für mich dort beste
Schnitzel bei Meister und Schaden
gegessen habe habe ich eine Woche später
bei Grubers gegessen dem Restaurant in
dem wir heute zu Gast sind und ich
dachte mir ist das wirklich so ein
großer Unterschied oder ist dieses
Schnitzel dass ich hier bei mir in der
Stadt Essen kann fast wenn ich sogar
genauso gut auf jeden Fall ist es aber
das Beste in Deutschland deshalb gehen
wir heute zum Restaurant Grubers treffen
den Inhaber und lassen uns erklären was
ein wirklich gut durchschnitzel so
besonders macht hier sind wir jetzt also
vor dem Restaurant Grubers und neben mir
steht Franz Gruber freut mich sehr wir
durften uns schon kennenlernen Franz
wirklich ein sehr sehr netter Mann und
er hat mich schon ein zwei mal hier mit
offenen Armen willkommen geheißen
deshalb freue ich mich heute nicht weil
du mir sympathisch bist krönen zu dürfen
für das beste Schnitzel Deutschlands ich
bin wirklich fest der Meinung dass es
das hier gibt im Grubers in Köln ich war
im Borchardt ich war in München
Schnitzel essen ich glaube wirklich dass
vielleicht nicht mal die
österreichischen Schnitzel an dein
Schnitzel rankommen das könnte daran
liegen dass du aus Österreich bist oder
ich bin jetzt seit 25 Jahren hier 27
Jahre sogar schon habe das Restaurant
nächstes Jahr 25 Jahre und wir hatten
jetzt viel Zeit um es zu üben dass wir
endlich mal richtig können ne genau wir
machen das schon sehr lange und das
klappt wunderbar aber wirklich die Küche
ist Sterne verdächtig und diese Gourmet
Küche auf ein Schnitzel dieser
Achtsamkeit auf dem Schnitzel angewand
zu sehen das ist ein gamechanger ich
würde sagen genug kennengelernt gehen
wir mal rein und du erzählst mir ein
bisschen was zu eurem Schnitzel gerne
Schwanz wir stehen jetzt vor der Küche
da hinten passiert gleich die Magie eine
Frage stelle ich mir was macht ein gutes
Schnitzel besonders gut die Frage stellt
sich bestimmt einige und die ist relativ
einfach zu beantworten es ist wichtig
dass man die Grundregeln des das
Schnitzels einhält sprich man muss
erstmal eine gute Produkt haben das
Fleisch ist ausschlaggebend welches
Fleisch nimmt man und wir haben da auch
schon hin und her probiert was ist für
uns das beste wir haben es von
karlsbrücken gemacht wir haben so eine
Katze Oberschale gemacht aber sind
zurückgegangen wieder zum Rücken
festgestellt haben das ist für die
Portionierung und von der Qualität der
für uns das beste und von dem her
gesehen ist der Karl Schritten für uns
eigentlich das optimale Fleisch um das
Schnitzel ordentlich umzusetzen was
anderes gibt für euch auch nicht genau
was gehört sonst noch dazu ganz einfach
eine Panade das Fleisch muss ordentlich
geklopft werden per Hand natürlich ne
wir drücken das nicht dürfen oder so
sondern jedes Schnitzel wird per Hand
geklopft und dann ist es wichtig dass
man ordentlich paniert ne Mehl gehört
was raus und das finde ich kann man auch
viele Küchen anwenden nicht nur auf die
österreichische auch die italienische
Küche die häufig wenige Zutaten hat da
müssen die Zutaten sitzen und die
Handgriffe müssen perfekt sein dann
kriegt man aus in dem Fall vier Zutaten
auch ein unglaubliches Produkt und das
machen wir jetzt beziehungsweise das
machst du jetzt ich bin gespannt los
geht's hier sind wir jetzt also in der
Küche und vor dir Franz liegt der
angesprochene Kalbsrücken ich finde es
interessant wenn ich mir das so angucke
wie soll das denn auf schnitzelgröße
kommen weil du wirst ja jetzt nicht der
Länge nach klopfen sondern ein Stück
abschneiden oder genau richtig ja das
ist eben der Vorteil wenn man jetzt so
ein Stück Fleisch vor sich hat dann kann
man auch die Portionsgrößen recht genau
einteilen so dass jede Schnitzel auch in
etwa die gleiche Größe haben welches
Gewicht weil das ist ja auch wichtige in
der Küche auch dass man wenn man kocht
das nicht das eine Schnitzel riesige ist
das andere wieder klein aber auch von
der Qualität und von der zarte Halt und
von der Saftigkeit her ist das Fleisch
natürlich perfekt ich habe auf jeden
Fall Hunger mitgebracht weil dieses
Schnitzel hier esse ich viel zu selten
weil ihr einfach so gefragt seid
irgendwie immer ausgebucht und ich bin
jemand der niemals weiter als einen Tag
im vorausfall deshalb sehen wir uns auch
so selten dann kann ich aber nur guten
Tipp geben wir haben ja mittlerweile bei
uns die Ansage gemacht dass die Gäste
wenn sie in Schnitzel bestellen wir
haben nicht diese riesige Schnitzel den
sie auch schon okay wir sind etwas
kleiner aber wir sagen halt wenn ein
Gast dann ein zweites dritte sondern
Viertel Schnitzel haben möchte kriegt er
das auch ohne den Aufpreis zu haben weil
das ist nämlich das was wir auch als
nachhaltig sehen es gibt ja Gäste die
sagen ich mit ein Schnitzel reicht mir
das wenn die Zeit drauf haben wird einen
weggeschmissen und da haben wir gesagt
wir haben das so eine Mischkalkulation
hergestellt haben gesagt der eine ist
zwei andere ist eine Schnitzel und
andere drei Schnitzel ich meine das
einer 5 Schnitzel ist das ist eher
selten der Fall und den er gesehen ist
das absolut das was wir probiert
wirklich auch damit punkten finde ich
nie die Erfahrung gemacht haben dass
einer 10 Schnitzel ist ja dann haben wir
Pech gehabt okay also bitte haltet euch
zurück wenn Ihr das seht und ihr müsst
Freunde essen sonst gibt's nichts ne ja
vielleicht ne genau jetzt kann ich hier
natürlich mit der Dicke die die ich
jetzt hier abschneide schon mal steuern
wie groß soll das Schnitzel endlich
werden kann das natürlich das dünner
schneiden Schnitzel aber die Schnitzel
sollen schon eine gewisse Größe haben
weiter geht's mit dem nächsten Part dem
Klopfen und da hast du ein Werkzeug
liegen das kommen wir relativ bekannt
vor genau aber dieses Werkzeug wenn ihr
euch ansieht der hat schon ein paar
Gebrauchsspuren der ist nämlich glaube
ich über 20 Jahre alt oh wow und wenn
ich mal hochrechne wie viel Schnitzel
wir im Jahr machen dann hat dieser
Hammer schon ziemlich viele Schnitzel
zerklopft ne aber er sieht immer noch
gut und ich habe keinen anderen gefunden
der so gut ist wie der deshalb immer
noch da Hammer das ist also ja ich habe
hier eine vakuumierbeutel genommen den
dazwischen liegt denn wenn ich jetzt mit
den Hammer einfach der Schnitzel
zerklopfe dann kannst passieren dass ich
das Fleisch total zerschlager weil eben
die der Hammer mit dem Poren eben das
vielleicht ziemlich zerfleddert
sozusagen ne hier mit der Folie werde
ich das Fleisch mehr oder weniger
platzieren was sehr viele auch machen
das einfach so ein glatten
Topfen Hammer auch verwenden viele
Fragen uns auch immer ob wir die
Schnitzel klopft kaufen ob sie durch die
Presse geben oder was auch immer noch
nein ich kann eine sagen
querschnitzel wird hier bei Hand
geklopft eine Person will ich hier auch
mal essen sehen und zwar den lieben
Lukas der wohnt nämlich in Wien und der
da letztens auch eine schnitzeltour
gemacht sich komplett durchgetestet ich
will auch mal hören was du zum Schnitzel
hier sagst so sah es vorher aus so sieht
es nachher aus eigentlich perfekt kann
man nicht anders machen wir werden immer
wieder mal von Gästen angesprochen das
Schnitzel ist aber so dünn geklopft ne
wenn ich ein Schweineschnitzel habe dann
ist es immer mindestens Finger weg
wahrscheinlich vielleicht einfach an das
ist von der Struktur
Herbst werden und das wenn jemand bei
uns sagt das ist ihm zu dünnen zeigt tut
uns leid aber dann sind Sie hier falsch
weil es gibt nur diese Art des
Schnitzels und da lassen wir uns auch
lass mal nicht in uns reden oh ich habe
so Lust auf dieses Schnitzel ich bin auf
die Idee gekommen das Video zu drehen
weil ich habe rein weiße Leuten gesagt
du musst zu drüber gehen du musst gehen
lass mir wieso bin ich eigentlich nicht
bei Google was und wie lange habe ich
diese Schnitzel nicht gegessen das ist
doch eigentlich das beste Deutschland ja
ich werde jetzt noch ein paar klopfen
und schauen dass ich euch gleich das
perfekte Schnitzel mache
ich habe jetzt mal gesehen wie es
funktioniert jetzt warte ich mich mal
daran Schnitzel zu klopfen könntest du
mir das vielleicht hinlegen wir sind ja
in der Restaurant Küche ne da bin ich ja
nichts falsch machen und der klopfen
einfach von innen so ein bisschen nach
außen hätte ich mal gesagt
aber man muss auch wirklich Kraft
anwenden ne
das ist nämlich genau das wo man
aufpassen muss dass man das nicht zu
dünn wird weil das ist er dann beim beim
Backen wird das dann relativ schnell
trocken kostet das ist jetzt die 2 minus
zwei minus finde ich gut in der Schule
wäre ich damit zufrieden gewesen
Schnitzel sind geklopft die panierstraße
steht wir haben Mehl ganz normale
verkühlte Eier und die Semmelbrösel hat
mir gerade erzählt sinnlich einfach aus
der Tüte ne dann legen wir auch sehr
viel Wert drauf ausschließlich Weißbrot
wir haben Bäcker der uns auch das
zugesichert hat dass er nur weiß wo sie
nehmen schön fein gesiebt und wir sieben
die größten nachher noch mal nach so
dass die wirklich schön fein sind die
groben Sachen alle rausgefiltert sind
sozusagen so dass man echt ein schönes
feines Panier haben ja ich finde gerade
so Aspekt Nachhaltigkeit so das sind
einfach trockene Brötchen vom Bäcker und
ich mein Sohn haben sie wirklich ein
sehr sehr guten verwendet gefunden also
wichtig ist auch und das machen auch
manchmal so finde ich es falsch indem
man jetzt hingeht und die die Schnitzel
alle würzt alles noch Verfahren
einfach so dass wird das Ei wird
gesalzen und pfeffert hier habe ich eine
Salz zum Pfeffermischung und zwar ist es
einfach der Vorteil dass das Schnitzel
gleichmäßig gewürzt wird sozusagen ne
und von dem abgesehen ein Schnitzel
braucht man nicht so stark zu würzen
weil wir nachher ja den Kartoffelsalat
dazu haben und die Preiselbeeren also
mehr braucht man eigentlich ja
die erste Station das Mehl ich mache
jetzt erstmal was was so ausschaut was
macht er jetzt das verklebte die da
versteckte die vor uns oder was nein es
ist wichtig dass das Schnitzel ein
bisschen im Mehl liegen bleibt und zwar
ist es so dass das Fleisch etwas das
Mehl ansaugt sozusagen ne dann schütteln
wir das überschüssige Mehl ab wird
paniert und dadurch so verliert nachher
das Schnitzel schön weil oft ist es so
wenn man sieht das Schnitzel klebt mehr
oder weniger die Panade klebt an Fleisch
fest das ist eigentlich das was wir
wollen die Panade soll schön locker auf
dem Schnitzen drauf liegen okay wie geht
ein Schnitzel auf das perfektes ist das
ganz anders augenscheinlich aber es ist
jetzt auch keine Kugel oder ja es kann
schon mal passieren dass dann in der
Pfanne wirklich eine Kugel passiert je
nachdem wie Konstellation von Fleisch
und Panade dann ist aber es kann schon
passieren dass das vielleicht richtig
aufgehende Kugel das gehört sich also
das ist so ja
nicht oder falsch das muss jetzt so sein
auf jeden Fall nicht ganz anhaften das
wäre falsch alles darüber hinaus ist
gern gesehen okay wir schütten uns dann
ab und das ist wie man sieht rundherum
schön mit Mehl oh ja ich kann jetzt
einfach mal eins ganz cool und lässt ne
schöne Ebene
leicht andrücken nicht jetzt so richtig
drauf drücken und fest drücken leicht
andrücken und das war's ne okay
perfekt das Schnitzel ausschauen
da ist wirklich jeder Quadratzentimeter
sieht so aus wie der andere also da sind
keine nackten Stellen nicht irgendwie
genau das sollte nicht sein weil dann
will man das Fleisch backen und das soll
nicht sein okay wir machen das so wir
machen das Wetter heißt wir paniert
kommt sofort
die Schnitzel haben dann sozusagen die
Möglichkeit sich zu frittieren beim
Backen ist es auch immer ganz wichtig
dass man ein paar Regeln beachtet ne wir
backen die Schnitzel ausschließlich in
einen Rapsöl und Butterschmalz wenn man
schon sieht da ist einiges an Fett drin
das ist auch wichtig man kann jetzt kein
Schnitzel machen
soll wenn man nur Boden bedeckt das muss
schwimmen okay so und viele denken sich
ja immer ja das kommt in die in die
Fritteuse oder so nein wir haben gar
keine Fritteuse von dem her gesehen das
Schnitzel wird jede Schnitzel wird in
der in der Pfanne gebacken nur dann
schmeckt er nicht und das bei 15 bis
20.000 Schnitzeln im Jahr das ist auch
auf jeden Fall eine Verpflichtung also
Butterschmalz wir machen das natürlich
auch selber wir kochen die Butter dann
auch sozusagen ne und das verbindet sich
auch gleich ah ja ich seh schon direkt
und noch ist es so zweifasig ja genau
ich bin gespannt ich werde auch nicht
drauf konzentrieren schmeckt man da
vielleicht was raus später aber
Temperatur Test mit ein bisschen
Paniermehl genau richtig ja also wichtig
ist auch dass das Bett nicht zu heiß ist
das soll nämlich nicht äh von vorne wenn
das zu heiß ist dann so fließt nicht
mehr ordentlich dann verbrennen sie mich
gleich dann aber wenn ich jetzt hier das
ist einige fängt an vielleicht zu
blubbert genau so und dann erstmal rein
und lassen es erstmal in Ruhe das ist
eigentlich wichtig wenn wir nachher wenn
es richtig schön heiß ist ja
aber jetzt schon man sieht vielleicht
doch jetzt schon
und das wichtig das ist dann immer ein
bisschen mit Fett überschwappt sozusagen
auch ne das ist ja dass du flieren das
eigentlich ja aber jetzt geht's richtig
gut ne 0,6 genau hebt sich die Panade an
und hier ist einfach wichtig dass man
ein bisschen mit der Temperatur regeln
man darf das jetzt nicht einfach
hochhalten und dann lässt man so weil
dann das Bett einfach dann sich
irgendwann verbrennt ja und dann muss
man da ein bisschen Gefühl reinbringen
auch ne aber wie man sieht löst sich die
Panade schön darauf es wird jetzt dann
gleich verwendet siehst du mal man kann
das sehen das ist schon mehr oder
weniger runter und gelöst ist ne wenn
ihr das hier man hört das Blubbern das
ist jetzt ein bisschen dass das
Flüssigkeit
je nachdem wie groß man haben möchte
kann man hier natürlich ein bisschen
länger drin lassen oder weniger und dann
kann man sich schon rausnehmen lassen
ein bisschen Fett ist noch drauf dann ab
man kann es auch auf dem Krepppapier
legen und das war's dann eigentlich
schon so so entsteht also das nach
meiner Auffassung beste Schnitzel in
Deutschland cool es gibt noch ein paar
die werden glaube ich jetzt auch noch
weg gebacken und dann kommt der
eigentlich beste Part das Probieren ich
freue mich schon sehr darauf genau an
die Arbeit ich werde euch jetzt noch
schnell auspacken
[Musik]
es geht los endlich dürfen wir das
Schnitzel essen ich freue mich so sehr
darauf hier haben wir noch einen
Kartoffelsalat vielen Dank und das
Schnitzel schon fast charakteristisch
nicht wirklich groß also nicht
gigantisch aber ihr habt ja gehört satt
gehen wir auf jeden Fall nicht nach
Hause das hat einfach wirklich was
besonderes schönes ich weiß nicht so ein
Schnitzel auch auf den Teller mit der
Zitrone und was besonders finde ist dass
es wirklich überall den perfekten
gleichen Bräunungsgrad hat wir nehmen
uns die Zitrone Tröpfe ein bisschen
drüber wir sind hier übrigens gerade in
der Mittagspause normalerweise sieht es
hier ein bisschen anders aus ein
bisschen belebter da drüben gibt's noch
Preise werden
also habe ich noch ein paar
Schnitzelchen oben drauf so wir
verstehen uns sehr gut was ist an dem
Kartoffelsalat besonders man kann ihn ja
gar nicht als solchen erkennen erstmal
von oben genau genau wir haben den äh
kartoffelgurkenswert der ist ganz
klassisch gemacht eigentlich auch wir
haben wirklich Kartoffeln Bio Kartoffeln
aus der Region hier und äh 88 drauf dass
sie wirklich perfekt sind für den
Kartoffelsalat die dürfen nicht zu weich
kochen sein weil sonst da fällt das
nämlich alles die Kartoffeln muss noch
erkennbar sein und um etwas mehr frische
reinzukriegen gehen wir oben drauf den
Feldsalat so dass wir dann einfach so
eine Mischung haben frischer Salat und
ein Kartoffelsalat gemischt wir
persönlich finden das passt wunderbar
und ich hoffe das könnt ihr auch so
sagen dann wünsche ich euch jetzt guten
Appetit lassen
genau wie beschrieben
Kartoffeln am schönen Biss sind schön
wachsen auch die Biene gerade außen rum
super lecker ich liebe auch diese
Mischung von Feldsalat und
Kartoffelsalat bei man hat irgendwie so
das Beste aus beiden Welten so können
wir auch da ganz kurz darauf eingehen
wie schön dieses Setting hier gerade ist
wie schön das Restaurant ist ne no joke
das sieht so krass aus gerade sehr sehr
stilvolleres Restaurant und ich finde
das wird auch den Wiener Schnitzel
gerecht welcher historischen absolutes
Oberklassen Gericht ist weil kein
Fleisch und so weiter und so fort ist
glaube ich die Zeit gekommen das Wiener
Schnitzel zu probieren ich probiere es
erstmal ohne alles hören wir einmal
so muss ein Schnitzel klingen und rein
in die Masse
wow wunderschönen dünn geklopft die
Panade hebt sich ab wird nur noch durch
die Gabel dran gehalten so sieht ein
gutes Wiener Schnitzel aus
das ist wirklich knusprig ich weiß noch
ganz genau ich habe in Wien bei meisten
und Schaden das als beste Schnitzel der
Welt gehandelte Schnitzel gegessen eine
Woche später hier und zwar warum sollte
ich nach Wien gehen ich kann das einfach
in meiner Heimatstadt
alles was ihr Franz gerade sagen gehört
habt stimmt das Schnitzel bleibt saftig
die Panade ist knusprig es hebt sich ab
man hat wirklich auch diesen buttrigen
Geschmack vom Butterschmalz auch im
Vergleich mit einem reinen Butterschmalz
ausgebackenen Schnitzel finde ich fehlt
da nichts das schmeckt so kräftig so
Vollmond ich so satt dass es wirklich
für mich das beste Schnitzel in
Deutschland die Beilagen super das
Ambiente wunderschön vielen lieben Dank
ans Grubers das hier drehen durfte das
ist ein echtes Schnitzel viel Spaß euch
falls ihr das Essen werdet ansonsten
sehen wir uns beim nächsten Video wieder
bis dahin und ciao